So let's step back a moment and look at
these results for these two extremes.
So we have this one extreme where we bet
all 1,000 chips on a single coin flip
and another where we bet 1 chip
on each of a 1,000 coin flips.
Now the risk adjusted reward or
the sharp ratio for
the single that was 0.63,
in other words if we bet
all 1000 chips on a single flip of
the coin our sharp ratio is 0.63.
So let's call this SRsingle,
now the sharp ratio if we bet
1000 times in other words 1 chip on
each of 1000 tables turns out to be 20.
So what's the relationship
between the two?
Of course, 20 is about 40
times bigger than 0.63, but
there's something more
interesting there.
And it turns out that it's this.
So if we take the single bet case and
multiply it by the square root of 1,000,
we get the sharp ratio of our multi-bet
scenario where we bet 1000 at once.
So isn't that curious?
So it turns out that in general,
if you carry that scenario out
to more examples, that if you
split your bets evenly across multiple
tables, this relationship will hold.
In other words, the sharp ratio for
the single bet,
1000 chips on one table,
is our base case.
And as we spread it out over more and
more tables, the sharp ratio improves by
the square root of that number of bets.
And this relation is exactly
like the fundamental law of
active portfolio management.
Namely, our overall performance
is related to the skill,
in the case of making a single pick,
times the square root of the number
of picks that we're able to make.
So our coin flip casino
has helped to show us
How we can derive an equation
like this for betting,
which is what buying [LAUGH]
stocks really is, and
to show that you can improve things
either by having more skill,
In case of coin flips,
skill is how biased is the coin.
In the case of investing,
it's how good are you at predicting
the future return of the stock.
Or you can improve your performance
by increasing your breadth, but
you only get to improve it by
the square root of your breadth.